so much remember but I'll probably
remember him for being a nuisance not a
troublemaker he really had a message
that we didn't understand but by being
kids he's bringing us something that we
can get rid of we couldn't get rid of
the town the man was a prophet he was a
prophet he had a vision for the whole
world but basically black people to show
them yes I can and you are bad you look
good you know we didn't hear that his
kid but he knew that and a kid so he
came to show us how great we were we
couldn't hear him and we rejected him as
a kid although we neighbors he live on
Grant I live in Greenwood next I'm going
to school every day it's always a fight
an argument but he was right so I
remember him so many thing but I'm gonna
remember the world should never forget
that he was a prophet a prophet that
prophesied my future and his future
about 16 and he transcended the world of
sports at source he crashes the were
loved everything because don't forget
now before I leave you and I probably
couldn't talk together the world was
segregated the world was if I wanted to
be something that decided they want me
to be that I'd be careful about that so
I'm glad you didn't grow up in that area
you don't have seen I left some of you
kids grew up now you never even knew
about
he felt racism he fought discrimination
he felt poverty he felt bad character he
felt that way through his vehicle of
boxing that was just a vehicle so we can
talk but he was actually a prophet and I
finally told him man you were right you
know I did and how did that feel being
able to but I don't know if he copy
anything at that time when I told him
they had built this museum in Louisville
Kentucky
I can I live in New York City I came to
Louisville Kentucky justice I've seen
him he was going humanness
serious I thought I needed to say
somebody's got then I did that's the man
you were right man he was right about
this right about that you're right back
to school
you're right about joint formal you
right about running King man he was
right about the bow but he was right he
was right I said it
I don't know when did you last see him
that was the last time I've seen him
because he was sitting there when they
brought him here to open up his lives
iam I I've seen that it was serious it's
time to say some stuff gonna realize
what we had the world in reliable had
none of us reliable in and we were
reliable we'd have we'd all been rich
because everything he promised had he
done if that one's got him for him a
meth way his mom and father lived you
know you were raised here
see it started here for him you know and
he'd shot a box right here behind us
he's at work he'd shot he'd shot a box
right here he would train and no he's a
chatterbox all up and down the street
old everyday chatterbox on you that's
all his whole life was when you first
thing you start talking swinging a tree
so let's learn a problem come on man
stop go away that's a kid but he's
talking he's telling you something good
for yourself you just get here soon you
try to share that message with you in a
very segregated place what okay the
whole Louisville Kentucky I mean with
black people lived on one kind of town
white live on another touchdown so if
you want to go to the other side of town
you got to get over the buck but you got
to get in the back seat hearing it so
you don't know nothing about that and
most of these kids right now they go
what does he say that it don't even
sound real do it but that was real a way
of living but he's saying that no this
is wrong I got white friends but I can't
play with I got people that I like but I
can't go to the same school as it I got
people I want to talk to but we can't be
in the same neighborhood something is
wrong this picture he said so he's
saying well wait a minute we got to do
something about it and the kid was
I don't know if you ever said it but the
key word when he demonstrated what it is
about your color no mailman it's about
your character you see so he
demonstrated a certain kind of character
to show people oh yes I can that's wise
counsel always tell you when you see a
black person oh you beautiful
are you a beautiful you think give you
the confidence coach me and the
knowledge you contradict what you've
been taught all your life if they become
in that area when he come alone sixty
years ago with either kid you know I
didn't see no God look like me in no
white house
does anyone see what happened though by
his encouragement by his telling people
yes you can you can do anything now kids
of all color go to school together
getting married
got job they come I mean up for living
the race is not an issue he want to
break that up
yes that's what his mission basically to
break up this foolishness think and he
just did it through a vehicle about to
cut he became the greatest boxer he ever
been but I'd like to look that on a
bigger picture
then the Prophet man while I'm telling
him to go away he wouldn't go with this
story his dedication this enthusiasm the
boxing it all started we hear from
getting his bike stolen he decided he
wanted to be able to defend himself well
I don't know that yeah I don't know if
he was just born to do this I don't know
I'm in moving that happen but that was
another guy who loved him so much and
told him all look what he seen such
greatness in hit about the bike come in
you want to defend yourself first of all
you learn how to fight you know but why
do you teaching him how to fight he was
teaching him how to fight another way
too
he was teaching him didn't talk about
that know that white man was telling him
boy you are great I want to show you
something bigger than that back man you
dare he seen some you tested for
something so he still competition
you know I don't know we still comedy it
drop some of that probably started with
him he may have been born with it I know
he's something different
Sonny Fischbach thank you very much
you're welcome thank you
okay folks I want to come in and get you
typically we can feel the passion at the
visceral feelings that he provokes in so
many people here heartwarming tales and
certainly the one theme that you seem to
keep hearing is that Muhammad Ali went
way beyond sport he was a humanitarian a
civil rights campaigner and a hero to so
many who lived here